yeah oh crap John it's your birthday
John 14:30 Oh John it's your birthday
this is a Hawaiian nose flute
[Music]
hey John thanks for bringing this book
to life it doesn't mean anything to me
in high school but now that I read it
again I realize how much junk is in the
trunk of this book happy birthday John
happy birthday John from all of us see
you happy birthday John
[Music]
happy birthday brother John you Hank
nerdfighters keep up the good work
god bless you all and never forget ft I
[Music]
have a feeling the bad part is going to
be figuring out how to get it all off
ain't got peanut butter in my eye
[Music]
happy birthday John I'm right they John
even though you're getting older I know
you will always be awesome nerdfighters
[Music]
by hybrid Pappajohn hippie brand hath
joy
had I been Jo pry fie
happy birthday John we're searching for
a song with John in the name to sing you
John Barleycorn John Barleycorn John
Brown
that's almost John Green let's just play
well done oh dear green tractor Johnny
Appleseed apples are great in it all
right John that's
[Music]
happy birthday - happy birthday
happy birthday happy birthday happy
birthday
[Music]
yeah